[Music]
and what's the ironic thing is
that
you don't have the police stopping them
so they're burning the quran and
it's something that saddens our heart
so let's go ahead and discuss this and
what we can do about but what we can do
about it and why
it's so important to establish what
we're trying to establish we're going to
be talking about that but let's get to
the quran burning
and see what is the solution to this
with my next
how are you good to be here i'm good
alhamdulillah so uh they're at it again
this is the way it is going on all the
way since you got a chance to see what's
going on across swedish cities yeah
somewhat
flashpoints have stemmed from a series
of organized rallies since thursday led
by the leader of a danish far-right
political party currently on tour in
sweden inflammatory events that include
the actual burning or threat of burning
of the koran
leading the rallies is rasmus paludan
so i believe this is in sweden but you
also have something going on you have
another lunatic
out there in norway doing the same thing
we got our brothers out there trying to
establish the masjid in norway they're
doing a fabulous job alhamdulillah may
allah give them success and god almighty
allah give them success
and the story goes i guess this guy's
coming along and he's putting up banners
and he's pretty much instigating and
trying to provoke and
coming out there and lighting the quran
on fire and then the police instead of
just nabbing the guy i don't think you
can even go outside
you know just in a public square
private property you're just going to go
burn garbage you're going to get a
ticket
that's not allowed right but you can go
ahead and just burn the the most dear
sacred book that's sent for all of
mankind the quran
and just have the police actually
protect you while you do it and help you
along the way
yeah this is unfortunate
when i see protests like that when i see
the burning of the quran when we see the
hate coming from certain people
it reminds me of an ayah of the quran
where allah subhana tala says that he's
the one in control you know he's going
to perfect his deen and is going to you
know he is going to be the one who is
going to take the deen to the next level
so this is so important for us yes
allah is in control at the end of the
day they cannot distinguish the light of
allah that's number one right number two
is as we have seen in the past this is
going to generate more kind of interest
by the non-muslims in the quran
in islam and generally you know what is
the deen of islam all about so more
people may become inshallah curious and
more people may learn about islam
from this unfortunate incident
and last but not the least more muslims
inshallah we can unite
and share the message
so more passion can be created in our
youth in the muslims and many many
massages
so unfortunate incident may create
something positive but we hope and pray
that may allah give hidayah to that
person and to those individuals so they
can actually see that islam is not a
threat
the masjid is not a threat our dhaba
centers are not a threat actually they
are a blessings to that country and to
all of humanity and that's where the
dean center comes into play
alhamdulillah what is the dean center so
people by by now they know they've been
seeing much of the ads and whatnot and
and it's
a direct
result of things like this that are out
there that now people are curious they
want to know who are the muslims what is
islam and then you have people like this
who are manufacturing this hate
because most people you know that i mean
i think you told me the story that one
time you were given a presentation
and a non-muslim he actually gave you a
check
he gave you his check is that correct to
support you getting out there and giving
the real message of what islam is
because he was getting programmed with
the wrong information just like this guy
who's burning the cronk he's obviously
got the wrong information so the dean
center will be out there to disseminate
the proper
information the right message so
inshallah can bring more love instead of
this manufactured hate and fear
you know education is the key and i hope
and pray when the deen center inshallah
when we are going to start many open
houses inviting our neighbors inviting
people like that who may not understand
islam
once they come and see the deen center
once they come and see the the wonderful
masajis and the peace and the way that
you know islam propagates the faith
inshallah i hope and pray that they will
see islam in a positive light and with
allah's guidance inshallah they can also
embrace the faith of islam so
it's important not only we need one deen
center we need deen center in every
state every city in the usa europe
around the world and that's why these
brothers are doing a great job brothers
in norway alhamdulillah may allah bless
them and their project they're trying to
do some good over there and they're
coming against you know lunatics like
this but you see the and now we're
trying to also do the same thing here
let's talk about the impact
of the dawah on this generation and the
next generation
yes
you know two days ago i was listening to
an imam right after the prayer he sat
down and he was uh
he was mentioning and he was creating
passion to help out the muslims in
kashmir in china in philistine in india
right the atrocities going on there may
allah protect all the muslims and may
allah protect all the people who are
oppressed because we are all humanity
right and we are all for for all
humanity oh then he mentioned that you
know we take our deen for granted in the
usa we can go freely to a masjid pray up
there freely come back home freely but
people in india different places they
don't have that guarantee they are
prevented from going to the massages
some of the massages are being you know
pulled down by this extreme ideological
people
so we take it for granted so he was
saying that you know we should thank
allah for what allah has given to us
but then i was thinking brother eddie
that the hate which is out there in
those countries and the violence and the
and all the discrimination that muslims
are going up there
exactly the same thing may happen over
here may allah protect us
exactly the same thing may happen over
here if we don't stop the poison being
exported from those countries to this
country
so if we so dawa is not just a just a
obligation it's a necessity for us
not only a necessity to to preserve our
massages and our person our physical
safety it's a necessity for the
ideological safety of our of our
children our youth our families
according to the pew research survey
this came out in 2018
23 of our of all muslims born and raised
in islam
they'd no longer identify themselves as
muslims subhanallah may allah protect
all of us right this is the reality if
we don't take care of islamophobia if we
don't educate the people it may come and
harm our children our progeny of our
families may allah protect all of us so
just sitting on the sideline and wishing
and praying is not enough
we need to do something the best
solution against hatred islamophobia and
violence like that is to peacefully
educate the people and this is where
deen center comes into play because like
you said this can spill over and now for
the next generation your children and
your grandchildren maybe we don't feel
the effect but that spills over and now
it's like a snowball effect it grows and
grows and grows and now you didn't have
the pr the public relations you didn't
have the education going you didn't have
any of these things set in place to
educate the people and you can have more
people like this who are popping up
burning the crowd next time not not just
burning the quran they're going to be
burning even more because we've had the
masjids many have attempted to burn
masjids down because of the lack of
education these people don't have the
proper education about islam and muslims
they need to be invited into the masjids
they need to experience what is some
some of the biryani and some other
the peace of islam right i mean
obviously biryani samosa
you have a good story you talk about
the imam
i called you you were going there to uh
to give a presentation and he said what
are we going to do he was all scared he
had all these people outside in front
with the
go back home uh this that and the other
these uh really uh
provoked uh provoking signs yes and you
said invite them in get some pizza you
know get some food invite them in and
the whole
the whole climate changed right yeah and
they came in the masjid so okay so this
is what happened i was going from one
budget to the next majid for some
meetings right some meetings and as i
was going past one other masjid
then i saw all of these uh you know our
fellow americans
they had this signs
against the masjid and they were having
this rally surrounding the masjid and
then i called the imam you know what's
going on there why are these people you
know all around the masjid and he said
that there is a rumor going on
in the neighborhood that there are
weapons of mass destructions in the
basement of the masjid what happens in
manchester and the mosque
and people are afraid i mean the
neighbors were afraid you know this is
the mosque and you know we'll be
compromised our children our families so
these neighbors non-muslim neighbors
were concerned
that if these weapons are there it is
going to jeopardize our neighborhood so
then they were having this protest of
concern right so then i advised to the
imam okay why don't you you know go out
engage with them
go and send somebody for some pizza for
some donuts and samosas and what not
invite them in the masjid let them see
the basement let them see the masjid let
them see how muslims pray let them meet
the muslims people have fear of the
unknown yeah break some bread
break some bread right so alhamdulillah
allah guided those people to come in the
masjid and they came and saw in the in
the basement also and they were muslim
kids they were reciting the quran they
were memorizing the quran
that looking at that it changed the
heart and the minds of these people all
the flags that they had waving you know
outside the masjid of concern
they left the flags in the masjid
they shook hands with the imam
they had smiles and that hate and the
misinformation it went away now they are
seeing that masjid and the imam and the
muslims in a positive light education
education education the dean center the
dean center the dean center that's what
it's going to be about insha allah next
next
point if we can go over the importance
of having the muslim media for our
identity
how important is this so important by
the eddie you know prophet muhammad
sallam during his time he used all the
available you know quote unquote media
to share the message as we just you know
went over in our day and age
you know i say media is the king right
media is the king
that means for us to amplify our message
we need to make sure that we reach out
to the thousands and the millions and
the billions of people we just cannot
rely on the fox and cnn and you know uh
all the radio channels yes they may have
their own agenda they may have their own
biases but we have to create our own
media
so we don't we are not at the mercy of
you know other media outlets
so
i hope and pray that our deen center is
going to have a really state of the art
media where we invite the guest muslim
guests muslim scholars non-muslim guest
right
and through that we become a voice of
islam right the voice of islam the voice
of the muslims the voice of peace
inshallah because the islamophobia
industry has become
with all the networks and media they
have this is a billion dollar industry
so now they have all this funding and
they're getting the wrong information
out that's going to affect you and your
family so that's the importance the dean
center in shaw law will have the dean
show in it we'll have the media in it
that's going to be perpetuating the
truth the right information
out there so people can go ahead
and really get to know what islam is
about what muslims are about
what we're trying to accomplish here and
it's opposite to the message that
they're getting out there from much from
the mainstream media and a lot of these
pundits out there that are you know
using this as a catalyst because of
people's ignorance people are ignorant
so you can take advantage so we got to
move that ignorance the dean center last
point we can go over is the importance
of
organized efforts to respond to being
in a position where we can respond to
the islamophobia that's out there
and the misinformation in an organized
effort
you know masha'allah the good thing is
that
compared to 20 years ago there are more
massages and more youth and more
individuals who are involved in activism
social activism social justice and
especially dawah
however there is still a big need
to join our resources join our the
blessings and the skills that allah has
given to us to have that you know
profound impact in the society so i
would say that outreach education and
dawah is a glue
to bring muslims together and the
massages together right and the muslim
activists together so the deen center
inshallah is going to bring the massages
together
and be a platform to provide services to
the massages where people can get
educated about what islam is our own
muslims we need to train our own muslims
how to break the eyes how to respond to
questions you know how to explain islam
especially we need to provide that
confidence in the youth
so there is a there is there is a way
that we can uh bring the muslim you
together to give them the confidence it
is going to bring uh the muslim dais
together inshallah right uh it is going
to a structure give structure to the
dawah programs not only in florida not
only in usa but we can set up a model in
the usa that can be copy and pasted in
europe and australia and all and all
over the world
so inshallah that is going to be a
force to unite our muslims together
inshallah with the deen center
alhamdulillah so
that's kind of just a brief overview
along with the the masjid there
the athletic facility
and the
media recording studio these are some of
the things that we'd like to be working
on and inshaallah with god almighty
allah's help
and with your support
inshallah we can make this a reality
and we'll be working together as we've
been working together for so many years
i'm in alhamdulillah i'm in
let me mention a profound story brother
eddie and especially to our audience
also here
i went to louisville three years ago
alhamdulillah we had a masjid open house
there invited the many non-muslims they
came they enjoyed they listened to islam
one muslim brother he mentioned this
story that still touches my heart and he
said brother sabio
i want you to listen to this story this
encounter be between a muslim family
and a non-muslim you know individuals
so one saturday this muslim family they
got a knock at the door saturday morning
10 am in the morning
and when they opened the door there were
two well-dressed people in front of them
so who do you think this may be saturday
morning
the
jehovah's witness was witnesses yeah our
friend's job was witnesses right so this
muslim brother he got really excited now
is my opportunity to share islam with
them so they had engagement nice and
friendly passionate engagement right
half an hour one hour passed by
they were asking questions they were
sharing their faith the muslim brother
was sharing his faith
and the q and a session about what islam
and what is jehovah's witness what
christianity
at the end of one hour the jehovah's
witness individuals they asked one
question
to this muslim brother who is
knowledgeable who had passion he had
education he was able to explain but
there was one question they asked him
and he became speechless
totally speechless and you may be
thinking brother eddie what question
that can be that this muslim brother any
muslim not able to answer
is it about jihad or sharia or women or
you know jizya about apostasy
okay take a guess what question it could
be what was it
if i were him
i would be speechless
if that brother was you
you may be also speechless
now brother eddie is thinking really
brother sabil come on man don't leave
her the suspense what is that question
that question is was this
jehovah's witnesses looking at all the
passion of this muslim brother they
asked him this question
they asked
if you are so passionate about islam
and you have spent one hour with us
explaining islam from your home with all
you know
evidences with passion and with
educating us
how come you are home and we are the
ones out there sharing our message
why are you home sitting at your home we
are the ones out there doing the work
what can he say
so message to you and me and to all the
muslims right we have to remind
ourselves if we care about islam our
children right about education about you
know sharing our faith with people we
just cannot only stay in the massages or
in our homes yes we have to stay in
masjid to do zika in the prayer but
prophet muhammad sallallahu islam he was
a person of action
he used to use the technology of the
time to propagate the message
so we need to really important we need
to not just be concerned about
islamophobia and to pray and to wish and
hope we need to put our emotions and
channel our emotions into action
and one of the best investments that we
can do for ourselves for our akara for
our children is to support the in center
because inshallah deen center is the one
along with many massages to take the
to take dawa to the next level and to
share the message and to teach people
and to invite them to islam and connect
the creation with the creator
muhammad rasulullah alhamdulillah
so you could be a part of history
and be a part of this journey that we're
taking thank you very much for helping
people understand more of the importance
of this project
and if you have any more questions
contact us otherwise go ahead and
contribute donate right now so we can
help make the dean center a reality
and we can have less of this quran
burning and more the quran reading and
if you'd like your free copy of the
quran go ahead and visit
thedeenshow.com get your free copy of
the quran and if you are about to burn
the quran why don't you read it first go
ahead thedeenshow.com
get your free copy of the quran postage
included we'll take care of everything
and if you still have any questions call
us 1-800-662-4752
and we'll see you next time go ahead and
support the dean center until then peace
be with you assalamu alaikum